careful this video contains manga
spoilers the moment the eight-year-old
momos sacrificed his childhood to
transform into a full-grown dragon and
face his greatest fears head-on in order
to save his country i knew that we had
just witnessed the climax of one of the
best character arcs in one piece
what's an incredible turn around for the
traumatized and mistrusting little kid
that luffy found in the depth of punk
hazard where he then turned into a
full-fledged leader in a matter of
months being able to hear the voices of
all things he does not only possess one
of the rarest powers in the story but
his ability to command the titanic
elephant zonesha suggests that he holds
even greater power still all on top of a
ridiculously powerful devil fruit
and i'll even go so far as to claim that
the annoyingly perverted side of momo
that made me dislike the boy right from
the start was written on purpose by oda
to give us the most satisfying
development that we can get as a reader
from hate to love because over the
course of wano momo has gained more and
more of my respect and i can now say
that i absolutely love him as a
character which is good because i've
long been subscribed to the idea that
momo is set up to be one of the most
important characters in the story you
know just like you should be to this
channel okay so let's start by
addressing the biggest criticism people
have for momo usually his pervertedness
which is great because it's
coincidentally the secret ingredient to
the success of his character
[Music]
and you might be thinking now that i'm
giving oda too much credit here and
maybe i am but hear me out momo's
perverted nature differs from that of
sanji or brook which for some people
muddies these otherwise fantastic
characters in that a this is a little
kid and b he actually does the things
that brook and sanji would love to do
but can't and i think that's important
because for sanji and brook oda clearly
thinks that it's a funny character quirk
and the fact that sanji's peep attempts
always end in violence is probably
supposed to make it a likeable thing i
believe even if for most people it
probably isn't
[Music]
with momo on the other hand the smugness
with which he uses his young age to do
what he does even from oda's perspective
is clearly meant to piss you off even if
you're someone that has no problem with
sanji and brook and find their perkiness
hilarious momo would still annoy you for
his smugness and so in my eyes this is
clearly a trait that is meant to give us
a false bad first impression of momo
when we meet him i actually think that
momo got this quirk mostly from the
people he grew up with like kinemon odin
rayleigh who are all pretty infamous for
their love of women
later on in wano when yamato sticks him
inside her shirt to protect him he
actually doesn't think anything pervy at
all fully in the process of accepting
his uselessness and preparing to grow as
a character the truth here is is that
oda wanted you and me to dislike momo
from the start seeing him as a perverted
spoiled and useless kid holding everyone
back because this way his change as a
character would just be so much more
drastic that way now i don't want to
exonerate him completely here i'm sure
he genuinely loves those boobs but i
also think it's important to consider
that this is an eight-year-old who just
lost both his parents as well as his
sister mere days ago and is terribly
traumatized when we first meet him only
we don't know that yet of course and so
when he gets to bathe with and sleep in
the same room as nami and robin i think
this is actually momo looking for some
much needed motherly love rather than
anything else what makes momo's ark so
special in retrospect not only in one
piece but in storytelling overall is
that his development breaks with two
very established tropes the typical hero
shonen arcs are a that from a boy to a
man or b that from a man to a leader boy
to man actually has nothing to do with
age per se but simply means that a
character needs to leave the nest
question their naive ideas and learn to
face the real world basically a
coming-of-age story usopp for instance
falls really nicely into that pattern
now the arc from man to leader on the
other hand means that a character goes
from being concerned only for finding a
path for himself to realizing that he
must help others finding their way as
well zorro and sanji are great examples
of this
and since i guess you're curious luffy's
arc is that from leader to visionary
going from helping a few others find the
right path to changing the whole society
i've always loved how these storytelling
best practices explain why one piece
works so wonderfully as a story luffy of
course has the most important arc but
all other straw hats have their own
protagonist storyline as well now you
might have already figured out what
makes momo an odd one out here his
character arc basically forces him to
combine a and b and go from boy directly
to becoming a leader momo despite being
a normal kid is suffocating under the
expectations of an entire oppressed
nation to become the same great leader
that his father used to be before being
executed days before meeting luffy
[Music]
talk about a tough spot to be in momo is
still too young to become a man and far
from being the natural leader that luffy
is and so this gives momo the ultimate
arc to work his ass off to go through
not just one but two character changes
at once and that way faster and way
younger than most other characters in
one piece and so once i had that
complete set of information available to
me in wano momo's arc became a lot more
apparent and interesting after losing
his parents and being sent into the
future on top of everything else he also
gets separated from the only three
people that accompanied him at this
point by the way making khandro's
betrayal later on that much more
impactful
he then has to survive alone on punk
hazard with no time to mourn his dead
parents and his terrible fates and so
understandably when he's taken in by the
straw hats he is initially very
distrusting only revealing his true
identity on zou after having slowly
warmed up to the crew's kindness as well
as their strength
[Music]
and although even at this point he's
already trying to live according to all
the expectations put on his shoulders up
until though he basically is still a
traumatized kid always put in bubble
wrap by his retainers and then on though
he has his first real moment of
character growth after revealing his
true identity he tries to assume the
role of leader but
fails
again is the one to teach him an
important lesson in true leadership here
and so at this point momo understands
what he needs to do in order to form the
big alliance to take down kaido and save
his country because being a leader means
that you are the servant to your people
and not the other way around i was
actually also incredibly impressed by
the way that he handled sunisha a bit
later even though suddenly having a
depressed ancient giant elephant talking
to you in your head understandably might
come as a bit of a shock for an
eight-year-old
bravo momo
now it is on wano and more specifically
on igashima however where momo's arc now
comes to full bloom for me first of all
it was clear to me and to you as well
probably that breaching his home and
facing the aftermath of all the horrors
he had to live through there was
overwhelming for momo now that it was
actually time for him to assume his
position as leader he quickly comes to
terms with the fact that he is not the
person everyone wants him to be the son
of the endlessly charismatic and
powerful odin
and so momo unsurprisingly sinks into
self-doubt and leaves most of the
decision making to luffy and the
scabbards he just feels helplessly
pushed around by the events now
unfolding throughout the country and so
interestingly enough i found it took a
real shock for momo to come out of this
stupor it's actually the three most
scary events in wano so far that bring
out the best in him first he's betrayed
and taken hostage by conjuro one of the
few people he had trusted the most for
all this time
and still instead of feeling defeated he
starts to fight himself for the very
first time next even worse he gets put
on a crucifix in front of the man that
had killed his father
[Music]
and given the option to save his own
life as a [ __ ] eight-year-old kid he
decides to die for his beliefs and
declares himself shogen anyway of course
securing him the immediate respect of
all his followers and finally after
learning the important role he has to
play from his father's diary he is faced
with the prospect of onigashima crashing
into the flower capital and so reaching
the climax of his arc he decides to
sacrifice 20 years of his life as well
as his remaining childhoods and orders
shinobu to age him to 28 years old and
what makes this decision even more
important to me is that at this point he
doesn't take the scabbards wanting to
protect him as an excuse anymore what
made this so emotional for me was that
momo knew fully well that this won't
change the fact that he's still 8 years
old at heart but it gave him the chance
to fight and make a difference finally
he can now fly up and deal with the
problem himself this boy has the courage
to face all his fears at once heights
kaido and a responsibility to lead and
he passes with flying colors i think
watching luffy for all this time has
taught him the most important lesson of
all you have to take responsibility for
what happens to you otherwise you'll
never be able to change anything and so
it's actually not that surprising i
think that he takes the form of the two
men under whose shadow he had to live up
until now kaido as a dragon and odin as
a human finally prepare to assume his
role and surpass both of them as leaders
given all of his powers and whatever is
written about him in his father's diary
momo is bound to be one of the decisive
characters once we reach the endgame his
inspiration after all is momotaro the
hero who got accompanied by a monkey
luffy a dog yamato and a pheasant
possibly aokiji
[Music]
all you need to understand is why luffy
was the only one who could have turned
this eight-year-old traumatized kid into
the next shogun of one and this video
will tell you exactly why